foreign
good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series is focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's chosen theme
is data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we'll enjoy presentations on
Fridays from leading thinkers about the
issues the promises the opportunities
and the hurdles associated with
understanding the secondary health
effects of covid-19 these include
delayed Health checkups treatments
Mental Health Health drug abuse
increased obesity in the long lingering
health effects associated with long
covet participants selected for our
biomedical data science Innovation lab
program will leverage these
presentations as vital material in our
culminating in-person Community
Development Workshop to be held at the
lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle
Washington in June of 2023. today I'm
delighted to welcome our speaker Dr Paul
Perrin from the school of data science
at the University of Virginia
all parent is a professor of data
science and psychology here at UVA he
received his Bachelor of Arts degree in
English and a BS in Psychology from the
University of Florida before going there
to receive his master's of Science in
Psychology and his PhD in counseling
psychology with a concentration in
industrial and organizational psychology
and systems intervention he trained
clinically at the University of Florida
Counseling Center and the spinal cord
injury and polytrauma units at the Tampa
Veterans Affairs Medical Center he
conducted an internship at Baltimore
Veterans Affairs Medical Center and the
user University of Maryland school of
medicine followed by a postdoctoral
fellowship at Virginia Commonwealth
University where he later joined the
faculty Dr Perrin is a licensed clinical
psychologist in Virginia and continues
to supervise Clinical Psychology
doctoral students in community settings
and in his research he uses a
combination of data science modern
analytic techniques and community-based
participatory research approaches as key
to understanding and identifying the
sources of Health disparities
this work covers three facets cultural
familial and international approaches to
disability Rehabilitation social
determinants of Health and Social
Justice approaches to understanding and
dismantling oppression in continuing our
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme Paul's lecture
today is entitled statistical modeling
and covid-19 early pandemic Telehealth
implementation and mid-pandemic
post-covered neurobehavioral symptoms in
Paul's presentation today he's going to
Showcase a diverse set of data science
approaches for modeling important
features of the covid-19 pandemic
including analyzes of variance linear
regression path analysis and network
analysis he'll present data and results
documenting and predicting the rollout
of Telehealth services at the beginning
of the pandemic by psychologists and
physicians in the United States and
he'll also discuss data and results
concerning the magnitude and patterns of
neurobehavioral symptoms and long
covered from across diverse Global
regions as all always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via
YouTube and if you're joining us on
YouTube thank you so much for joining
also our specially selected 2022-2023
biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged
to submit any questions for Paul via the
chat feature in their Zoom sessions I
will synthesize these questions and I'll
ask them on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that Paul thank you so much for joining
us we've been really looking forward to
hearing what you have to tell us about
all right well thank you so much for the
invitation to present and to everyone
for attending this talk today and thank
you Dr Van Horn in particular for going
through my agenda so I don't need to do
it again but yeah essentially this is
going to be a two-act performance if you
will so I'll be talking about the
rollout of Psychology Services in the
U.S at the beginning of the pandemic and
then I will be presenting some
information on a neurobehavioral symptom
magnitudes and patterns in Long covet
all right so for uh that First Act
um so this is uh I'm going to be
presenting the results of two different
papers uh from a single data collection
so these papers were published in 2021
in the American psychologist and also in
the journal of clinical psychology
um
in order to talk about telepsychology we
should probably start by discussing what
it is so you know telepsychology is
broadly defined as the provision of
Psychological Services via technology
and unfortunately before the covid-19
pandemic very few psychologists were
using telepsychology in their clinical
practice only about 21 of psychologists
across the U.S endorsed that use of
telepsychology
there are a number of deterrents and
reasons why psychologists didn't want to
use it or were unable to use it
um you know they they broadly had
concerns surrounding practice so things
like having received insufficient
training in their doctoral or a
postdoctoral programs and not knowing
how to handle client safety or crisis
issues that might come up maybe
insufficient Demand by the patient
populations that they were working with
and also they had concerns about the
efficacy you know they were not sure
whether telepsychology approaches to
clinical work were as effective as
in-person modalities
they also reported a number of
environmental and policy concerns so
issues of privacy you know using the
right type of video conferencing
technology to to ensure inpatient
privacy big concerns about legality for
example if you know patients across
state lines then you know what happens
with a provider's license when they're
licensed to practice in a particular
State a lot of ethical issues that can
come up around confidentiality
reimbursement problems for services by
Managed Care organizations
and also just prohibitive organizational
policies and cultures a lot of providers
were working in environments where there
were just explicit rules against using
telepsychology for their clinical
practice
but you know as uh everybody's aware in
March of 2020 uh March of 2020 the who
declared uh the covid-19 uh pandemic and
as a result there was just profound
shutdowns in schools businesses
institutions and a lot of uh Human
Services transitioned to online models
and one of the biggest changes that we
saw had to do with Health Care delivery
where a lot of elective procedures were
being postponed in routine patient
visits were also being postponed or
conducted virtually but at the beginning
of the pandemic no studies had
documented the shifts in Psychology
clinical practice to telepsychology
despite a lot of widespread and
first-hand accounts and providers saying
that they had made this shift
so as a result we decided to launch a
study right at the beginning of the
pandemic and our purposes of this study
were one to examine the amount of
psychologists telepsychology use before
The covet pandemic during the pandemic
and then their anticipated use after the
pandemic ends
second was to examine the demographic
training policy and clinical practice
predictors of these changes then the
third was to use key elements from
respected Behavior change models to
develop and test a theoretical model of
psychologist adoption of telepsychology
use during the covid-19 pandemic
so for uh participants to to be a part
of the study they had to be licensed to
practice as a psychologist in the U.S at
least 18 years of age or older and
currently practicing or in other words
seeing patients as a psychologist within
the United States so data were collected
from May 11 2020 to May 25th 2020 and as
a result uh the the paper that came out
of this the first paper was the first
paper uh documenting the rollout of
telepsychology services across the U.S
so it was published July 20th of 2020.
um so for recruitment uh we we sent
initial and follow-up email invitations
to about 27
000 psychologists so we CL we pulled a
bunch of contact information from
publicly available email lists websites
Clinic contact information sites and
then we got about 3 600 participants who
started the survey so about a thousand
of these individuals didn't provide
informed consent didn't complete the
survey or they provided kind of
nonsensical or impossible responses or
they had lack of a meaningful response
to a validity check question so our
final sample was
2619 licensed currently practicing
psychologists
sorry it's stuck
yeah there we go all right here's what
these folks look like so their average
age was uh 57 in their average years in
clinical practice was 24 years so this
is actually a pretty well seasoned uh
sample of psychologists uh about
two-thirds were women about 91
identified as white or European American
and these demographics uh generally
mirror the overall demographics of the
membership of the American Psychological
Association
a lot of these individuals were
individual practice so 54 percent
reported being
um you know in an individual practice in
the community 15 in a group practice and
then largely in other types of medical
centers whether that's uh VA medical
centers academic medical centers
outpatient treatment facilities
psychiatric hospitals
uh 46 were in a suburban area 44 we're
in an urban area and about nine percent
in a rural area
and about 44 of these psychologists were
the only ones in their private practice
uh 33 had about two to five
psychologists in their practice and then
a number particularly those who were in
Health Systems had a much larger number
of psychologists in their practice
so when we defined uh telepsychology to
these participants we called it the use
of real-time audio for example telephone
and or video conferencing technology to
provide Psychological Services
and we asked psychologist what
percentage of your patient treatment is
provided using telepsychology and so
they responded from zero percent to one
hundred percent
and we asked them to respond with regard
to three different time points so one
was before the covid pandemic began in
the U.S on January 20th 2020 which was
when the first documented case occurred
in the United States during the covet
pandemic in the US so in other words
currently and then your anticipated
perspective or behaviors after the kova
19 pandemic ends in the U.S
and here are results
so before the coveted pandemic about
eight percent of clinical work was
performed via telepsychology
during the pandemic about 85 percent was
performed via telepsychology and then
psychologists estimated that about 35
percent of telecent of clinical work
would be performed by a telepsychology
after the pandemic ended
um so you know we were doing work in the
context of telepsychology in this space
for a number of years before the covid
pandemic and a big goal of ours was
really to try to increase the adoption
of telepsychology and the research has
suggested that it is equally as
effective as in-person treatment for
literally every type of evidence-based
practice that has been tested and we
could not get much movement in the
uptake of telepsychology no matter how
many presentations we gave
research articles we published and so
because of this incredible shift we
called this the telepsychology
Revolution and it truly was a revolution
there's a 12-fold increase in uptake of
telepsychology
and as you might imagine this was a
statistically significant change partial
Ada squared of
0.863 we're not supposed to call things
very large size effect but it was a very
large size effect
when we broke this down about 45 of
psychologists reported not using
telepsychology at all before the
pandemic and then 85 percent reported it
for using it using it 10 or less of
their clinical work so very very little
use
um before the pandemic during the
pandemic 96 of psychologists reported
using it in their practice 67 reported
that they were going completely virtual
during the pandemic and almost 78
reported using telepsychology for 90 or
more of their clinical practice
after the pandemic 89 percent of
psychologists anticipated continuing to
use it in their work
so then we broke up using just a series
of analyzes of variants
um who what type of psychologists were
likely to use telepsychology during
these different time periods so before
the coveted pandemic we had the highest
use of telepsychology with the by those
who are working in VA medical centers so
the US Department of Veterans Affairs
has been a huge proponent of
telepsychology and Telehealth and
they've really been a forerunner in the
context of the provision of services via
Telehealth
that was followed by individuals in
private practice so we're seeing people
who probably had a lot fewer barriers to
practicing telepsychology because they
could just make their own decisions as
an independent practitioner
conversely of those who worked in
outpatient treatment facilities had the
lowest use of telepsychology before the
code pandemic followed unfortunately by
those in academic medical centers
during the pandemic the highest use was
from those in individual practice
lowest use was by a psychologists in
hospital and Medical Practice
and then the change in telepsychology
use is a little bit of a wonky variable
to look at so I won't present it because
it has to do with how much they were
using it before versus the change but in
terms of projected use afterwards after
doing bond for only Corrections we found
no differences in the projected use
after the coveted pandemic would end
so again just robustly across the board
we're seeing people who are very very
likely to be using telepsychology
we then conducted a simple linear
regression
to see what demographic characteristics
might predict increased use of
telepsychology during the pandemic so we
found a positive a small size effect of
psychologists who had been trained
sufficiently in the use of
telepsychology they were more likely to
use it during the pandemic
those who worked in an organizational
setting had supportive telepsychology
policies were also more likely to use it
psychologists who identified as a woman
were more likely to use it and there was
a lot of research literature published
at the time about women having to play
kind of dual roles of you know working
and then also looking after kids and
taking sort of a differential burden of
child care responsibilities so we
interpreted this uh in line with that
larger literature
and then there was a very very small
size and barely statistically
significant effect of rural locations so
psychologists who are practicing in
rural areas were less likely to use
telepsychology during the pandemic which
was a bit surprising to us and might be
in line with kind of social distancing
Norms in rural regions that were
occurring in the us at the time
psychologists who treated anti-social
personality disorder were less likely to
use fellow psychology and we thought
that a lot of these folks might be in
kind of forensic settings like
correctional facilities
those who perform testing and evaluation
were less likely to use telepsychology
as many psychological assessments
actually have not been adapted for for
telepsych administration
psychologists who treated relationship
issues were more likely to use
telepsychology and this is also in line
with a lot of research literature
suggesting that couples conflicts and
domestic violence were increasing during
the pandemic so psychologists who tended
to treat these were probably very likely
to be able to use those services to um
to provide care
psychologists working focusing in
physical medicine and rehabilitation so
this is taught populations like
traumatic brain injury spinal cord
injury and also a lot of psychologists
who are working in medical centers those
folks were less likely to use
telepsychology
and then so this was just looking kind
of a basic demographic so here we've
seen the use of really basic analyzes of
variants to look at mean differences in
in use of telesite whether that's based
on before the pandemic during the
pandemic or projected after we also saw
this looking at different practice
locations then we're moving to
regression modeling to see how either a
different focus of treatment or also
different demographic characteristics
predict a higher percent use of
telepsychology
but we were interested in a little bit
more complex modeling Beyond what's
traditionally used in Psychology
research
um and there's been two predominant
models of behavior change uh in the
research literature that we wanted to
draw from to see if some of the
variables within those models especially
if we used path modeling might describe
some of the uptake of telepsychology so
the theory of reason to action is a very
traditional model of behavior change it
was developed in 1975 and it's been
applied to a lot of different topics
like health behavior change
for example you know changing one's diet
or engaging in exercises or medication
adherence
and it's kind of a basic model but the
idea is that there are subjective Norms
around particular behaviors like if you
uh you know are a part of a social
network that's very likely to exercise
or eat healthy
subjective Norms affect behavioral
intentions to engage in a behavior and
then a person's attitudes about that
behavior also are likely to affect their
intention to engage in that behavior so
whether they think that the behavior
will be effective in its outcome
um and then that behavioral intention is
theorized to lead to actual Behavior
change
so then this model we had attitudes
toward telepsychology subjective Norms
about the use of telepsychology so
whether psychologists believe that other
psychologists were likely to use
telepsychology all of those things
channeled directly into intention to use
telepsychology which then uh
transitioned into current use of
telepsychology
so the uh the parameter estimates here
are all standardized beta weights
and when a lot of times when researchers
conduct a path analysis they'll start
with What's called the saturated model
so they will draw all potential paths
within a system of theorized connections
and so that's what we did so we had an
additional path going from attitude
toward telepsychology to current use of
telepsychology and you can think of each
of these as kind of standardized beta
weights within a regression so each of
them is the unique effect controlling
for the other effects within the model
so there was no statistical effect of
attitude toward telepsychology directly
on current use of telepsychology once we
control for intention to use
telepsychology so that is considered a
full mediation
with subjective Norms going to intention
to use telepsychology and then current
use we still have that additional beta
weight of 0.12 and the systems of
indirect effects the two possible
indirect effects here or mediational
effects of intention to use
telepsychology were statistically
significant so from subjective Norms
because there is still a statistical
effect there we would consider this a
partial mediation
now the cool thing about path modeling
is that you can sort of draw out a
theoretical model
and then you can apply fit indices to
that theoretical model to see how well
the real world data actually map on to
your model
and so over here we have a number of fit
indices NFI IFI tli and CFI where 0.90
is or higher is considered adequate 0.95
or higher is considered a good fitting
model rmsca the root mean square error
approximation traditionally 0.08 or
lower is considered adequate 0.05 or
lower is considered good and we have a
AIC and Bic Criterion as well so here
all of the with the theory of reasoned
action all of the fit indices were
excellent they're actually perfect
and so overall we found pretty good
support for the theory of Reason action
in describing psychologists use of
telepsychology in their clinical
practice
right we then also had the technology
acceptance model which is a specific
model applied to use of a new technology
and so it was uh developed in 1989 and
of course was not really applied to
telepsychology until uh more more recent
times uh and we were the first group of
researchers to apply it so here a person
believes that a new technology is useful
or not over on the left they also have
perceptions about the ease of use of
that new technology
those two variables are theorized then
to drive attitudes toward using the new
technology which then drive behavioral
intention to use it and then drive
actual system use
so here we did the same thing with
perceived usefulness received ease of
use going to attitude toward
telepsychology to intention to use
telepsychology and then current use of
telepsychology
and then within the model perceived
usefulness generally exerted a stronger
statistical effect on attitude toward
telepsychology than perceived ease of
use did
and it uh also exerted an effect
directly to intention to use
telepsychology so all of the possible
indirect effects or statistical effects
including multiple mediational effects
were statistically significant within
this model so we're seeing sort of good
internal support for it based on that
system of inter of indirect effects
um
but then we're also seeing a partial
mediation of attitude toward
telepsychology on the relationships
between perceived usefulness and
intention and then perceived ease of use
and intention and then so this model is
describing for is explaining 47 percent
of the variance and intention to use
telepsychology and then 33 percent of
the variance in current use and we also
had excellent fit indices here not quite
perfect like we did with the theory of
Reason action but nonetheless extremely
good fit indices so we're finding
support both for the theory of Reason
action and also for the the technology
acceptance model
for describing why psychologists might
or might not be using telepsychology
during the pandemic
so the implications of these findings is
you know we had excellent fit of both
these models and so the models suggest
Pretty right targets for increasing
psychologist provision of telepsychology
both during the coveted pandemic but
also Beyond
so there are a number of changes that
the centers for Medicare Medicare
Medicaid
um implemented in terms of reimbursement
of telepsychology at the same rate as
in-person visits and so what we're
arguing is that you know some of those
policies are extremely likely to
continue to increase
psychologists perceptions of the
usefulness and improve their attitudes
toward the use of telepsychology so we
highly recommend that you know
governmental agencies enforce you know
comparable reimbursement structures for
telepsychology versus in-person business
and again all of the literature suggests
that they're equally effective and so
why not reimburse them at the same rates
particularly to support the continued
rollout of telepsychology services
we also recommend that
legislation particularly that involving
HIPAA with regard to practice across
state lines and license revision for
services across state lines
um you know continuing to support those
changes what ameliorate concerns related
to legality and confidentiality that
psychologists have that have been found
over and over in the previous literature
is one of the major barriers and again
if we remove that barrier then you know
we're theorizing that a lot of the
variables in the theory of Reason action
and Technology acceptance model then are
going to increase in the positive
direction which then set off that
theoretical Cascade of effects
all right end of act one we can
transition now to act two uh focusing on
neurobehavioral symptoms and long covet
so uh the the findings from this uh uh
for the for this part of
um the talk are going to be from a
single study also although a separate
study from uh the first one that I
mentioned and this is part of two papers
that were recently published in 2022 in
the journal Inter National Journal of
Environmental Research and Public Health
all right so you might have heard of the
term long covet it's also uh been called
persistent post covet syndrome and it's
a set of symptoms that appear after
infection by the SARS Cove 2 virus and
that persists for four weeks or more
After The Infection some researchers
have uh have um given it sort of a eight
week uh or longer time window although
uh four weeks or later is is fairly
common in the research literature as
well
now long covet is more common in
individuals with severe Copa 19
presentations but it also can appear in
people who had mild infections and so
some of the symptoms are ones that you
might be familiar with these are things
like fatigue General bodily pain
headaches breathing difficulties anxiety
and depression
but there also are a lot of long coveted
neurological symptoms including
headaches dizziness loss of smell loss
of taste also a more serious
neurological conditions like prolonged
loss of consciousness stroke
encephalopathy meningitis seizures and
demyelinating diseases
there are three overarching theories
about why long coveted neurological
symptoms exist and so the idea is that
the virus attacks the brain and you know
these theories do have some scientific
support to them so the first is with
direct virus infection to the astrocytes
so astrocytes are these sort of
star-like structures within the central
nervous system that are thought to
regulate cerebral blood flow among other
functions
second is overreaction of the immune
system which has been termed cytokine
storm
and then also a blockage of blood flow
in the brain causing causing hypoxia or
a lack of oxygen
so when we conducted this study the
literature is really lacking in Long
coveted studies and particularly those
with large sample sizes those from
diverse Global regions and also those
using validated instruments so a lot of
researchers were kind of creating their
own yes no checklist of symptoms that
may or may not actually have been
validated psychometrically
so the purposes of this study were to
compare the presence of somatic
cognitive and emotional neurobehavioral
symptoms and a large International
sample of covid uh International sample
of individuals as recalled before their
covid-19 diagnosis during their covid-19
infection and currently or in other
words at the time of their survey
and then we wanted to examine risk
factors for increased long coveted
neurobehavioral symptoms
and then finally we wanted to apply a
network analysis to investigate the
patterns of somatic cognitive and
emotional neurobehavioral symptoms in
the subsample of Spanish-speaking
individuals with a history of covid-19
positivity and we want to compare that
to a separate non-covet control sample
so we recruited a thousand and one
adults from 32 countries who had
previously tested positive for covid-19
Via a viral or antigen test
and 650 of these individuals were
Spanish speakers from 26 countries and
they averaged 175 days since their
diagnosis or since testing positive for
coven 19. so the data were collected in
March to June 2021 so fairly early in
the pandemic and this is right when
vaccinations were beginning to be rolled
out in developed countries and
particularly for high-risk populations
so it's important to say as a caveat the
vast majority of people who participated
in this study had not been vaccinated
we also had 443 covid-19 negative
covid-19 negative Spanish speakers from
19 countries so we knew that these folks
were coveted negative because we had
collected data on them before the
covid-19 pandemic
so participants were recruited through a
professional mailing lists and
collaborators contact networks so we
used Facebook groups we paid for
advertisements on Facebook and then also
we were collaborating with one Center
that had a covid-19 patient database
this was a Mount Sinai in New York
the participants completed an online
version of the neurobehavioral symptom
inventory so it's a 22 item self-report
measure of symptom severity across
cognitive effective and somatic domains
and it's generally been applied for
neurological conditions like mild
traumatic brain injury
so participants reported each symptom at
three time points so before covid
during their covid-19 infection and then
now when they are completing the survey
so here are the results so this is the
subscale score for the somatic symptoms
so you can see over on the left
participants free covid-19 scores which
as you would hypothesize just shot up
dramatically during the covid-19
infection and then you also saw some
improvement so here these indices are
Cohen's D where point two is considered
a small size effect 0.5 a medium size
effect and 0.8 a large size effect
so we see a medium-sized Improvement in
somatic symptoms from during the time of
the covet infection to now
but the thing that was fairly disturbing
to me is that there was a an almost
large size effect the Cohen's D of 0.76
from before covid to now in terms of the
increase in somatic symptoms so on
average 175 days later we're still
seeing an almost large size increase in
reports of somatic symptoms
and then when we broke apart that
subscale we found that the biggest
remaining symptoms were still from uh
participants report of their sense of
smell
bodily numbness and dizziness
then looking at effective symptoms we
saw that same huge jump and then a small
size Improvement in effective symptoms
but a large size increase in those
effective or emotional symptoms from
before covid to now so we're seeing
tremendous continued mental health
problems in individuals who had a
history of covid-19 infection
and then within that subscale the
largest continued problems were
pre-coveted fatigue and sleep problems
then for cognitive symptoms
again we saw that huge increase from
before kovitz during covid and then we
actually did not find a statistically
significant Improvement in cognitive
symptoms
175 days later on average so that
Cohen's deed did not even reach a small
size Improvement
conversely there is a large size
increase in cognitive symptoms from
before the coveted pandemic that
remained 175 days later on average
within the subscale the largest
continued problems were reports of
concentration problems and then reports
of forgetfulness
we then ran some regression models for
the somatic cognitive and effective
domains
in step one this was a hierarchical
regression so we had a number of
demographic variables
and then in step two we added in a
number of other kind of covid specific
variables and so here I'll just be
presenting the results from step two so
we found that people who identified as
male so men reported lower levels of
somatic cognitive and effective symptoms
we found that individuals with another
chronic health condition other than
covid
reported higher levels of systematic
cognitive and effective symptoms
we found that individuals who had
received oxygen therapy reported lower
cognitive symptoms so again these data
are correlational but you could infer
that oxygen therapy
um helped moderate the development of
coveted symptoms
individuals who reported higher covid-19
severity during the time of infection
report a higher somatic cognitive and
effective symptoms
and then unfortunately days since
diagnosis was associated with
symptomology but in a positive direction
so greater number of days since
diagnosis we're seeing higher levels of
somatic cognitive and effective
symptomology when we're considering this
cross-sectionally in the context of the
overall regression model and that is of
course controlling for all of these
other variables
uh we decided to look differentially by
global region I will say that interpret
these data with caution because it's
hard to know whether a snowball sampling
approach in these different countries is
what uh accounted for some of these
differences you know where you know one
person might have shared it to their
Network and then that network is more
homogeneous in a particular Global
region but nonetheless we did find
overall that uh individuals from North
America and Europe and Central Asia
reported higher levels of somatic
symptoms severity relative to those in
Latin America and the Caribbean and
relative to those in sub-Saharan Africa
we found that same effect for Effective
symptom severity higher rates in Europe
and Central Asia and North America
and then we found the same effect for
cognitive symptoms severity again
highest in North America followed by
Europe and Central Asia and then
sub-Saharan Africa and Latin America
so again you know you're seeing
um kind of traditional
um psychology Behavioral Science
approaches with anovas and regression
modeling so we were interested in
applying more modern data science
approaches to our data so we decided to
apply a social network analysis to the
650 Spanish speakers with long coveted
and then a separate sample of 443
individuals without a covid-19 history
so the purpose of social network
analysis is to model among other things
clusters of related symptoms as a
dynamic system
so in order to conduct this analysis we
use the estimate Network function from
the bootnet package in R we use the Epic
glasso routine to estimate a network of
partial polychloric correlations which
you can think of as you know partial
correlations or a relationship among
variables controlling for all other
relationships in the net
we use regularization which is a machine
learning algorithm that repeatedly
reduces the smallest edges from the
network to zero and then iteratively
re-examines model fit and we compared
the two networks so this the uh 650
individuals with the history of long
covet or a history of covid and the 443
individuals without the cobit history
we compared those two networks
statistically using a 500 aeration
permutation test from the network
comparison test package in r
all right so graphically here are the
two networks so over on the left we have
the long covid network over on the right
we have the control Network
so yellow nodes or yellow symptoms are
the somatosensory symptoms
the blue symptoms are the cognitive
symptoms and then the green ones are the
effective symptoms
so over on the the right is the long
covet Network well we can immediately
see is that by comparison the control
network is largely disjointed relative
to the long coveted net
so the somata sensory symptoms kind of
form their own symptom cluster and don't
actually bridge to any of the other
symptoms so it's kind of a diffuse just
pattern of symptoms in individuals
without a history of covid and then in
those with long covid we're seeing
actually kind of a organized
interconnected set of neurobehavioral
symptoms
then when you look within the models one
of the biggest differences that we found
was the relationship between the
organize and headache nodes so in the
long covet group we find a pretty big
connection between those two so the
thicker the line the stronger the
connection among those those variables
of those nodes
and then we find a very little
connection between the organized and
head headache nodes in the control net
so does that mean that headaches are
causing people to have organizational
problems or does it mean that there
might be some organic brain damage in
the context of long covid that's
creating headache pain and then also
creating organizational issue it's hard
to know these data are all correlational
but nonetheless we're seeing that those
those two symptoms in particular are
highly related to each other
particularly relative to control group
all right so if we're going to draw some
conclusions we have to think about a few
limitations so you know again we used an
online snowball sampling approach and so
there's definitely some
non-representativeness of these samples
we're not in any way saying that this
represents
um you know an entire global population
clearly there are a lot of global
regions that were not well represented
like in Asia
um also the uh the study was
administered either in English or
Spanish and as a result yeah everybody
had to speak those two languages so
there's profound limitations in how far
the um of the data collection can
actually spread just based on linguistic
limitations
and you know participants also might
have recall bias when they're comparing
their current symptoms to those either
during or before an active covet
infection
so um I I would argue that
very likely the uh the reporting of
telepsychology used by psychologists was
going to be a lot more accurate because
it's a very kind of concrete behavioral
anchor where when you're thinking about
covid symptoms you have people who have
more mental health issues or more
distressed might retroactively view
symptoms that they had before the
pandemic as uh being kind of higher in
magnitude or
um you know and so as a result there is
some response bias that you have to take
into account but nonetheless we're very
consistently finding that individuals
with that history of covid are reporting
continued symptoms and much higher
symptoms than they had before the
pandemic
now in terms of implications
um you know it's just you know we're
finding that just incredible
um you know consistency across you know
all three domains of reporting these
substantial continued symptoms
um and so you know we're also seeing
evidence that long covet is a coherent
identifiable pattern of neurobehavioral
impairments now you might find uh this a
little bit depressing uh because you
said oh my gosh you know they're based
on you know coveted rates so many people
are probably experiencing these issues
and it is true there are a lot of
neurobehavioral impairments out there
that people are experiencing and there
are neuropsychological tests that are
showing evidence of that as well but
what I will say is that there are
emerging cognitive Rehabilitation
approaches that have been found to be
extremely effective at treating
long-term neurobehavioral symptoms so I
have colleagues at University of Alabama
Birmingham who have found great evidence
already for uh some of their cognitive
Rehabilitation approaches so you can
think of these as like almost you know
stereotypically like brain training
games where they do different types of
cognitive exercises
um that help people kind of adjust and
you know regain function from
neurological conditions so this has been
applied to traumatic brain injury stroke
and now we're finding evidence that it
applies pretty well to to Long coven and
so we're just arguing that those type of
Rehabilitation Services and particularly
cognitive rehab are critical for
individuals reporting elevated
long-coveted symptoms
now if I were to take kind of a step
back and obviously this is a data
science
colloquium series
and so you know here we've showed that a
diverse set of data science approaches
for modeling important features of the
covid-19 pandemic can include really a
heterogeneous set of analyzes so things
like analyzes of variance linear
regressions path analyzes and network
analyzes and I would argue that each of
these approaches can answer you know
very different research questions even
using the same data set so you know a
lot of times researchers will start off
with just describing means and standard
deviations and looking at differences
among groups on some variable of
interest and then maybe they you know
work their way up a little bit further
to you know regression models where they
might think of certain predictors and
try to you know fit the best regression
model that they can to you know
predicting some outcome
but even still I would argue the field
still needs to you know take those
approaches and move forward so you know
have uh theoretical models that you can
test using path analyzes or even more
kind of bottom-up exploratory approaches
like network analysis that don't
necessarily presuppose
um a prior existing Theory but
nonetheless can be very complementary
because they're data driven they're
inductive rather than deductive
so you know it's really this combination
of traditional and more modern data
science approaches that you can be
extremely synergistic to paint the most
comprehensive and nuanced pictures of
patterns and data
all right that's the end of my talk this
is my email address if you have any
questions feel free to get in touch with
me and I'm happy to take any other live
questions that you might have
Paul thank you so much
um I know that there was a question that
you might have touched on and given a
satisfactory answer but I wanted to kind
of cycle back to it is that in the in
your the first
um portion of your talk where you were
talking about like pre-covered there
were barriers to the telepsychology
usage by practitioners do you feel that
that was due to just resistance by the
the psychology Community towards the
efficacy of it do you think it was a
technological barrier that people just
didn't want to change but kovid's sort
of forced it upon us or do you think
that it was a consequence of the
perception that the patients or the
recipients of that that telepsychology
wouldn't get as a a quality experience
from it did you have a sense of that
from your data
yeah pre pre-covered we did collect a
lot of data
um you know from psychologists on their
perceptions about kind of barriers and
and facilitators of telepsychology use
and so you have a lot of what I call
kind of like you know uh interest
psychic barriers so these are ones that
the psychologist perceives
um so this can be things like you know
the bias against you know telepsychology
being effective I mean I think that
that's probably a huge one I've heard a
lot of providers especially before the
pandemic say well you know
telepsychology is just as not as
effective as when I'm meeting face to
face with with a client or a patient and
yet to be honestly the evidence for that
statement is not there
um in fact the vast majority if not all
research that have uncovered has
suggested that telepsychology approaches
are just as effective as in-person
approaches now there are some
limitations to that if you think about
like a neuropsychological assessment
or other forms of Assessments that
require some sort of like behavioral
Criterion or response from from the
patient
um it is true that those are more
difficult to administer and to evaluate
you think about like IQ tests for
example are a little bit more difficult
to do
um you know over over telepsychology
um but yeah the vast majority of
research has suggested that there's
there's no difference the only
difference that has emerged is there's
been some research suggesting that the
relationship quality is a little bit
better although a very very small sized
effect better for in person versus over
telepsychology
um and then yeah I think a big issue too
is people just were never trained I mean
believe it or not like I mean how many
times would we have zoom meetings before
the pandemic existed like right almost
never and so you know people were using
Skype or um you know other approaches
where they would talk to friends and
family but not necessarily in a
professional setting all that often so
people just were not familiar with it
and then there also were a lot of I mean
I think in um in defense of
psychologists there were there is there
are um patient issues that come up so
you see issues of bandwidth where you
know particularly in rural areas or um
you know if people people are on kind of
data limited plans
um it can be very difficult for them to
access telepsychology well
and so yeah I've been randomized
clinical trials looking at the rollout
of you know telepsychology interventions
for example for you know caregivers of
older adults and I would say that about
a third of the caregivers we work with
are just simply not able to connect over
a smartphone or over a computer and we
have to go through just straight up you
know a telephone
so you know there are those kind of
practical barriers but you know I think
a big thing too is just not the intro
psychic but the environmental barriers
of um you know the you know managed
payer environments
um you know if if psychologists cannot
get reimbursed for services at the same
level that they can in-person Services
despite there being no evidence that
there should be a difference then
um
yeah they're going to want to do
in-person work just to Simply you know
make more money and that makes sense
right if they're running a business
um and then also there are all these you
know kind of odd ethical issues that
come up across practicing it across
state lines and is it where the
psychologist is like that's where their
license is if you go on a vacation out
of out of state then can you no longer
practice or is it where the patient is
um so you know there I think there are
some sort of structural and policy
barriers that create a lot of that
resistance as well thank you Paul um
there were in your um your the study
that you described where you're looking
at the various factors that's um
contributed to you know pre-dring and
post covid I was struck by some of the
other chronic conditions that you uh
kind of categorized uh but that ended up
being a particularly strong effect and
I'm just kind of wondering if you could
comment more on the role that possibly
covet or the experience of covid may
have had on those pre-covered
comorbidities did it like cause them to
become worse was it just kind of
compounded and piled on top of them
would they have just experienced you
know more symptomatology more more
symptomatology anyway uh do you have any
insights there
Yeah well yeah in some of those
regression models
um the presence of uh the additional
symptom was controlling I'm sorry the
additional health condition was
controlling for all other variables in
the model including you know severity of
cobit 19. so what we were seeing is that
there's an added burden on
neurobehavioral symptoms of having that
additional chronic health condition
um but there has been some research
looking at kind of interactions where
you know particularly people who have
cardiovascular issues
um how that impounded with uh with a
covid-19 infection in terms of producing
um you know disparate out outcomes like
additional hospitalizations
um you know more neurobehavioral
complications so yeah that's absolutely
been a big one
um yes we've we published a study
recently looking at covid-19 vaccination
uptake in individuals with chronic
health conditions exactly because that's
that's such an important topic of you
know seeing you know folks who who have
those additional conditions as being you
know really important for you know
encouraging higher levels of vaccination
rates to ward off some of these symptoms
that we're seeing here that they're at
additional risk for
in your social network kind of analysis
that you performed uh where you showed
that you had certain Bridges between
certainly some of the somatosensory
symptomatology and some of the mental
health symptomatology yeah there thank
you for bringing that graph up you have
various what you call Bridges there and
I'm wondering you sort of touched on it
about causal mechanisms here and I'm
wondering if you have any
any further comment on those or any
other insights that that people could
take away is when they're performing
analyzes like this what they need to be
aware of in terms of making causal
inference
yeah causal inferences are super tricky
particularly when you have
cross-sectional data so even though we
have this kind of faux longitudinal data
of looking at these variables and asking
people before during and after the
pandemic
the methodology itself of collecting the
data cross-sectionally prevent
additional causal inferences that you
might be able to engage in if you're
looking at longitudinal data so um you
know whenever possible if you can
conduct conduct these studies
longitudinally do multiple waves of data
collections then you can use cross-lag
panel techniques to help infer relative
causality among pairs of variables and
controlling for other variables within
the model
um here yeah I mean this at the end of
the day this is really a cross-sectional
model and yes we're controlling for
every other symptom in the network but
you know nonetheless it's it's
cross-sectional so we can't say that one
of these symptoms one of the bridges is
due to one node or One symptom versus
another
um you can of course rule out any you
know sort of third variables
um by you know controlling for for other
things like if we wanted to control for
you know age or control for presence of
another chronic health condition to say
that that's not causing these
relationships but nonetheless it's very
difficult to say that headaches cause
organizational problems or
organizational problems call up cause
headaches you know because the basic
structure of the study itself is not
causal
so you know in Psychology we have uh you
know an experiment which is uh differed
from other forms of studies like
correlational or cross-sectional studies
because the methodology itself controls
for every other possible variable
wherein it's only an experimental
manipulation that can cause a change in
a dependent variable but it is much more
difficult to do this uh
cross-sectionally although there are
there are folks who try to do it by just
you know controlling essentially for
everything you can
um and then seeing what's left you know
and one of your take-home messages I
thought was really important is the
notion of
taking a data-driven approach you can
apply some of the methodologies that
you've described here
uh you can apply Ai and machine learning
Technologies Etc that are very popular
right now but it's really important to
have a theory of some kind that is
testable and can be validated and can be
uh examined that helps to explain the
patterns and the data that you're seeing
so much of our uh I don't know so much
of the stuff what we're seeing these
days are oh we just threw every machine
learning algorithm at the data and we
just found the one that classified you
know again the best percentage
classifier and there's no reason other
than the math worked out in our favor
and that seems so Theory free that it is
probably worrying especially in cases
where you're looking at clinical kind of
predictors do you have any comments on
further comments on that
yeah I mean you know that within the
discipline of psychology there's the
famous quote you know there's nothing so
practical as a good theory and you know
I think that psychology tends to be
pretty good at having a theory for how
variables relate to each other what
might be causal what kind of you know
Cascade of events might occur and you
know we also have you know decent
methods that have been well accepted in
the field like path analysis structural
equation models where we put we
specified a theory ahead of time and
then we collect data to support the
hypotheses that then support that theory
um but yeah in the context of machine
learning approaches you know when I've
had conversations with a number of my
colleagues in Psychology about this
because this is a huge area for me he's
trying to bring more machine learning
more data science approaches back to the
discipline that I've been trained in
um I do get that resistance you know
they say well you know we're concerned
about the replicability of these models
because it you know to some extent
they're based on you know a single
sample even if it's a large stand sample
nonetheless it's
sometimes these machine learning
algorithms are so good that they're
capturing variants that's there but it's
actually just chance variants relative
to that specific sample right so you
know can we also bring some Theory to
the variables that we're choosing in uh
and you know specifying as being the
most important in the context of these
models can we sort of start with that
theory and use both both approaches
right I mean there's there's something
about deductive reasoning and you know
deductive science and also about
inductive or more kind of data driven
um uh empirically based science where
you know the data are telling you the
story versus you telling the date of the
story and then asking if that's really
the story so I think you have to
approach it from from uh really both
methods
I think that's a very important point
and thank you Paul for sharing your work
with us and having a little chat with us
um we know you're you have a busy day
ahead um so we'll we'll let you go but
thank you so much Paul this was really
great and thank you everyone for joining
us and uh everyone have a wonderful
weekend and we'll see you again next
week thank you
thank you